uh welcome um
i am pleased uh to announce
the conclusion of the rapid
response strike force appointed by
governor cisservac
to identify issues and make
recommendations regarding
the state's unemployment system
i was honored to be appointed to lead
the rapid response strike force
to examine our system uh the first task
uh when appointed by governor cisserac
was to find
a new acting director for dieter
the previous acting director had stepped
down after threats on our life
to our great pleasure uh elisa caferetta
agreed to take the helm i've worked side
by side with her
over the past five months and i am
pleased that she was appointed
permanent director this past week by
governor sisilak
she is the right person for the job and
i have been impressed by her dedication
to this department over these past five
months
our second task was to create the
volunteer strike force
i want to thank the strike force members
and a number of them are here on this
call
vanessa alpers david axtell
alisa cafferetta alan cunningham
steve fisher anthony pearl
mike schmidt and chuck short
these talented team members brought with
them
a variety of skills and analyzing
systems
backlogs understanding i.t
fraud they brought perspectives from the
state system
from the private sector they're problem
solvers that care
about the state and they
made this journey much more enjoyable
and productive
because of their skills and talents over
the last five months
we have spent hundreds of hours
analyzing
our unemployment system
and offering solutions many of which
were implemented immediately
and others which can be implemented over
the long term
a few highlights first
key leadership positions inside dieter
and the employment security division
say for one contract employee key
leadership
positions in the department and the
division
were either filled with inexperienced
leaders or vacant
you can't run an operation in crisis
without steady accomplished leadership
at the helm
since that time every leadership
position has been
filled of course with alisa at the helm
deputy director of deter a new esd
administrator linda parvin one coo
two new deputy administrators and two
new chiefs
i've had the opportunity to work beside
them over the last
several months and they're a talented
team
the second key issue that we found
insufficient staff to process claims
some baseline numbers we've prepared
a pretty exhaustive report
38 pages it'll be posted
on the website if you
look at page 20 of that report you'll
see a lot of the baseline numbers
so from march 15th to
july 31st that's the time when the
strike force
began 406
100 191 regular ui
claims were filed during that same
period
344 691
pua claims were filed by
august we had over 300 000 claims being
processed
and you can compare that to a pre-covet
level
of 20 000. uh remarkably
at least one week of benefits was paid
to over 500 000 claimants
by december 31st 1.5
million claims were filed
when the strike force began there were
245
[Music]
765 claims in the backlog
26 470 were in the ui
part of the house and 217
197 were in the pua backlog
the division was certain that many
most of the poor claims were fraudulent
but legitimate
nevadans were caught in in that pile
at the time of the pandemic esd had 181
employees
by august there were 362
employees not counting the alarica
contracted staff
but still there were not enough staff
to process the cases and
hiring in the state system takes time
at that time steve fisher administrator
of the welfare division
suggested adding welfare eligibility
workers to the mix
he thought they were already trained
to process claims in accordance with
sometimes
arcane federal law they were already in
the state
system so they joined the effort
it's the first time in the state's
history that this was
ever even considered much less
undertaken
and 200 state employees
joined the effort from the time they
were hired
through last friday they processed 88
064
cases a remarkable amount of work
today the backlog is also
can be seen on page 20 of the report
for the ui cases that were there when we
started the backlog is now
zero of those who had monetary
eligibility meaning
claimants could get money on the plural
side
there are 16 000 left from that original
217 000 and it's believed that all of
these are fraudulent because none have
yet
uploaded documents
at the same time esd consid it continued
hiring
so today there are 746
employees now attacking the claims
a note about the current status of
claims
as you clear a backlog of course more
claims roll in
the difference now of course today is
that you have more
staff and more automated systems to
process them
if you turn to page 21 on our report
you can see the current backlog of the
current backlog the current number of
cases
that are awaiting and our
recommendations to resolve them
so for example in pua
there are 7 709 cases with documents
uploaded
meaning the claimants took time to
follow the instructions
and upload their documents at the
state's current resolution rate
we estimate that 3083 will be eligible
with a current processing rate of 5 000
a week
the welfare staff can clear this
remainder by
february 7th we're recommending
then that the state mass resolve the
other cases where
no proof of identity exists and no
documents were uploaded completing the
pua backlog
by february 7th for ui
there are 26 353 cases
pending more than eight weeks we suggest
that when the poor backlog is cleared
that the welfare workers be
transferred to the regular ui cases
assuming they're the same
resolution rate of 5 000 a month
when they join the current ui staff
which are processing
8 000 a week i'm sorry 5 000 a week
for the welfare workers the esd workers
are processing
8 000 a week we estimate that the ui
cases can be cleared
in two months as you can tell
in ascertaining workload
and backlog the strike force did a
number of things
we catalogued the claims along with
dieter staff
we assigned staff we tracked resolution
and processing rates
to ensure that claimants received
a more timely answer we recommend those
same approaches
continue this
the next area i'd like to address in
addition to leadership
claims processing in the backlog is
fraud
much has been said about fraud in the
unemployment system
but to put it in some perspective more
applications have been
filed than our people in the state's
workforce
that means hundreds of thousands of
fraudulent claims
nevada is not unique our
identities have been stolen and are
being
sold on the dark web that means
for the first time the the fraud that
is being seen in unemployment offices is
not
claimants fudging trying to get an extra
week of benefits
but criminals who have your name
address social security number and date
of birth
and who are firing claims in people
real people's names
when this first happened and the system
was besieged
it really stalled everything and that is
when the governor
appointed the strike force when the
strike force began
um again there were
a large number of claims in the backlog
the division thought they were
fraudulent but
you know what to do about it so the
strike force helped member mike schmidt
ran analyses to compare the list of
claimants
to other databases to determine
authenticity new technologies were then
rolled out new vendors were selected
because this fraud is nationwide
there's a number of vendors who are
getting into this business
of identifying who the real folks are
putting these systems in place at the
front end
so a new contract has been entered into
by dieter along with existing contracts
and now we'll be layered on because this
is
not a problem that's going to go away
all state systems will have to get ready
private sector systems will have to
get ready because of the massive level
of id fraud that is going around our
nation
so while much still needs to be done to
keep
one step ahead of these criminal rings
dieter is no longer stalled by these
criminal networks
and are using these technologies to get
benefits
to the true nevadans who are waiting
but the workload that's been created by
this
you have claimants calling not the real
claimants not being able
to get benefits because a fraudulent
claim has been filed in their name then
you have to make sure the person calling
is the real person
and so the amount of time having to be
spent
on these cases one by one
is truly a problem and i'm very hopeful
that the department of justice and at
the fbi cyber task
investigators are going to begin taking
a larger role because the same criminal
networks are targeting every state
the next topic i want to talk about is
system modernization
the computer system serving esd
is slow and outdated it's been
unable to keep up with the volume of
claims
as a result a decision was made early on
to
outsource the pura computer system which
brought its own set of challenges
there was recently an analysis done on
the system
and it concluded that the system relies
on
highly complex costly
third-party products that require
extensive maintenance
they're brittle with tons of workarounds
it needs to be replaced in the meantime
we have two systems that don't talk to
each other
so modernization needs to occur
the other problem with these systems is
they
don't report great case management
reports tools that can be utilized in
prioritizing claims
the reports produced by the ui
system they count issues
one claim may have six issues well if
you're trying to sort out the backlog
you want to know how many people are in
it not how many
issues are in it it keeps track of
fraudulent folks who are in the system
again just making it really cumbersome
when you're looking at a system
inundated with claims
you want to be able to sort them catalog
them
prioritize them and process them
the computer systems made that extremely
difficult and the strike force is
recommending
replacement
um the last topic i want to focus on
is improving the claimant experience and
better crisis planning
so the system uses complex forms
confusing instructions there's not
enough claimant updates
you have pool not talking to ui two
separate systems
these were just some of the complaints
that the strike force
heard by october esd staff
began cross-training all the welfare
employees
on both pura and ui and
some of the previous staff also were
trained that way
so they can see both systems so that
we're not
shuddering people back and forth social
media efforts were improved
we recommend that a business process
review be implemented looking at every
step of the process
looking at things that were added to the
process perhaps decades ago that no
longer makes sense
have a real claimant look at the forms
and give feedback
on whether they're understandable
these are things that can improve the
system
and make it better those
five areas were probably the highlights
of
the report but we really looked and
touched it
on just about every aspect of the
operation
we were planning on sticking around
studying the system within 60 days
90 days but honestly the one of the
biggest problems
facing the system was a lack of staff
power and
being so far behind so
our team decided to stick around to
offer suggestions solutions
meeting weekly and not just have this
you know study be put on a report that
actually be implemented
a number of the recommendations have
already been implemented
and some will come in the future
it was my honor to serve the governor
and the state
over these last several months while
much still needs to be done we are proud
that a new leadership
team is now in place an
innovative staff plan was implemented
the initial backlog was virtually
eliminated
and anti-fraud measures were installed
and that a future backlog elimination
plan was
formed to reduce cases filed after the
strike force
was formed while my many challenges
remain
with the new department leadership in
place we are confident that the
department will meet those challenges
and continue to serve nevadans in need
nevadans deserve no less
with that i'll ask alisa to
also make a few comments
good morning thank you uh
barbara um i want to
make sure you can hear me first
um and i'll i'll keep going okay
great so i wanted to start by thanking
uh barbara buckley and the strikeforce
for their incredible dedication and hard
work
this was a really great team from with
folks from the public and private sector
and they volunteered i think they they
thought they were volunteering as
barbara said for a month or two
to take a good look and they ended up
digging very deep into the complexities
of unemployment law
processes and systems and they they
truly did give
hundreds of hours to this uh complicated
cause i wish that we could share the
story of every one of the
thousands and thousands of nevadans who
eventually got a determination
or a resolution or who got their full
allotment of benefits that they were
entitled to
or continue to receive
because that's really what we're all in
this for that really was
the goal is getting people an answer and
getting
eligible claimants paid on the behalf
of all of those claimants who we serve
i want to thank the strike force again
for their work
in sort of getting this process unstuck
as barbara described it and i want to
especially thank barbara buckley
who recruited and led this really
all-star effort
you don't get this level of commitment
from volunteers
and engagement without a talented and
trusted leader
and we really couldn't have done it
without you so thank you again
barbara this was an amazing
[Music]
work to be involved with
and we are going to miss you and we will
call you every once in a while when we
have a specific question where
we can use your expertise so of course
the question is what is next for dieter
as barbara noted even though we're
almost done
with the backlog we have thousands more
applications
to process process as they continue to
come in
so our plan is uh has several
points to it that i'll share with you
first of all uh
as we've discussed we do have a few more
probably weeks or months to get current
and our goal is to get
current and stay current on the claims
processes
so we will continue the weekly backlog
elimination
meetings to keep track of our progress
redeploy staff and resources where they
are needed most
and as we say get current and state
current on the claims
processing the second thing that we are
committed to
which we haven't talked about in detail
in this press conference but is
ongoing is making sure claimants receive
all of the benefits that they are
entitled to
and as you know congress continues to
pass new legislation
which provides additional benefits so
currently
that means finalizing the computer
programming
and the regulations we need so that
people can get the extensions that
congress passed
and the continued assistance act
specifically we're still working with
the department of labor so we can
implement the pandemic emergency
unemployment
compensation which is extra weeks
without cutting into or eliminating some
of the state extended benefit weeks
that claimants can get so we want to
make sure they get all of the weeks they
are entitled to
we are also working on updating the
programming for
new pua applications to make sure they
comply with the new
documentation requirements in the law so
that work is ongoing
the third area of focus is leveling up
our efforts to
address fraud as as barbara noted this
continues to be a huge
issue for us so we are upgrading
our technology and our staffing
solutions to prevent fraud before it
happens
as well as working with law enforcement
to investigate and prosecute
fraud after it occurs
and to reclaim those funds where we
possibly can
the fourth area that we're focused on is
to start doing
more to get people back to work uh the
there is some good news in our economy
it's still mixed for nevada but
uh people are going back to jobs so
we are working on being as innovative
as we can and connecting people to the
workforce services
that we currently provide online and
we're expanding those
services as well because we want to make
sure people have the skills
and supports they need to return to
their jobs or new jobs
and finally as as barbara mentioned
modernizing the computer system
is a key priority for us all
i think many of you know the governor's
budget does include
some funds to invest in computer
programmers
software and hardware that we need to
take immediate action
to stabilize our computer systems in a
way that will allow us to
speed up processing and increase the
system security as we face these ongoing
attacks and we're also working with the
governor's office
based on this recommendation to find the
funds and develop
an rfp to thoroughly modernize the
system in the next two to three
years and to
to wrap up my remarks um i would be
remiss if i didn't recognize the
amazing amazing work of the dieter staff
throughout this entire crisis the state
and the agency were hit with
unemployment numbers that have never
been seen by any state
ever and
that was followed by a tsunami of
applications and unrelenting attacks by
fraudulent actors
the theater staff have been putting in
overtime for months giving up their
nights and weekends
sort of an unending attempt
to get caught up on the backlog
they've been subject to some pretty
harsh criticism
uh and yet they've stuck it out so uh
and they've they've done that to make
sure that
every week week in and week out about
300 000 nevada families have been
getting
their unemployment benefits and the
deter staff
through it all made sure that over 8.3
billion dollars
in unemployment benefits have gone out
to nevadans in need
so there's certainly much more to do but
i know that this
incredible staff is going to continue to
show up and we will get it done
those are my remarks and i think we
are ready to take questions
this is rosa just a couple of reminders
to all of our attendees
please remember to be courteous of
everyone's time
go ahead and ask your initial question
and then allow for others to ask their
initial questions
thank you go ahead
rosa will you be calling on people or
would you like me to do that
that's fine i'm trying to watch the chat
oh okay
i'm following the raised hands
so joel muller saying they can't um
unmute themselves it looks like
there we go can you guys hear me yes joe
we can
there we go all right thank you so much
um
two pretty simple questions here one is
to do with the i know you talked about
the systems and software and technology
and everything
um obviously the phones have been an
issue throughout the past um
what is being done to address that and
get phone lines operating
at a better capacity and then also i
know
we've talked about this in the past with
the backlog some people have fell
through the cracks um and they're still
waiting i've obviously been in contact
with some of those people
are is there a system coming being
constructed to address those people who
might have fallen through the cracks who
are still waiting
yes so um taking your
second question first for those who are
still
waiting there are
plans to get through every single case
when those folks call the call centers
their claims are elevated and given to
an adjudicator
and they're resolving those cases at the
same time
any claim that hasn't had a
determination is going to one of the
200 welfare workers to resolve
so our hope by that february deadline
is that every pure case
in the backlog will have a determination
because the 200 extra workers have been
going through them
one at a time they finished 88
000 we estimate that there are
you know two to three thousand left who
are owed benefits
those will be next to be resolved with
regard to the phone system
if we can solve people's problems they
won't need to call as much
if if there's claimant communication
through the media through releases they
won't have to call as much
the response times have gotten
they are still not where they need to be
and i'll tee that over to elisa to talk
about
what she thinks is on the horizon for
the
overwhelmed phone systems yeah
so the phone systems uh it's not the
systems themselves it's also
a staffing issue of course and so
um i think barbara outlined
the highlights of the the best things we
can do is resolve cases
uh get people the answers that they
need we are also working on
uh frequently asked questions
chat bot feature which should be able to
help provide
just basic information to claimants
without needing to call into the call
center
one of the things we've seen happening
in the call volume is every time
congress passes a new law and there are
new benefits
extra weeks uh the additional payments
people start calling to say when will i
see it
um and so that that that sort of
overwhelms the call center for a while
as we get through those calls so
uh if the program features will
stabilize and we can just be paying
people's benefits that's going to help
and again as we we've talked about you
know the
the the best thing we can do is keep
redeploying the staff
to the place where they can kind of get
through backlog
um and then fewer people will have
questions so that that is the plan to
add some more staff as we can to the
call centers
to get to those calls more quickly
thank you joe next up is we have a
question from michelle rendells go ahead
michelle
please remember to mute yourself
sorry can you let me know um
you guys have reported specific numbers
from the backlog
uh in today's report do you expect to be
able to quantify the backlog of claims
and publicly report that information
kind of a regular potentially weekly
basis going forward
um obviously i'll tee that over
to alisa that just from an outsider's
point of view
um it is extremely time consuming to do
that
it has to be done by hand because the
computer systems
don't produce the data that you need
um so if you're going to do that it's
going
to take tons of hours and the first
priority
is to try to get through cases and pay
people
so you know my recommendation would
probably be periodic updates
as opposed to trying to do it every week
when we started i tried to do a
dashboard
right um i thought that you know they're
doing it in other systems
and i thought it would be just a great
feature to add
wow i mean it just proved impossible
to do that regularly again because the
system
is producing issues well people don't
want to know how many
issues are pending they want to know how
many people were pending
so at least i don't know what your
future plans are with regard to that
yeah i would say um you know we
we have a lot of reporting
responsibilities to
the federal government for all of the
funding streams that we have so
we are doing regular reports to
the department of labor they as barbara
said they don't
they don't match sort of things that
normal people would be
interested in you know sort of issues
resolved or number of issues that we
have in certain categories is
is not what people are interested in i
do believe
that there are when we get current
um there are certain performance
measures
that dieter has used traditionally which
i think
we will which are in the system which we
can report on on a regular basis
for example what what week of claims are
you
working on when you have
literally half a million claims that
came in sort of in may and june
your processing may and june claims for
a long time and that's not really a
meaningful number of
where your progress but once we get
current
uh that will actually be sort of a very
understandable
standard that we can report on on a
regular basis
so i agree with barbara i thought one of
the first things we're going to do was
the dashboard and
that that proved to be
you know just one more thing that's it's
a lot more complicated than
it sounds
thank you okay the next we have up is uh
darcy spears
jesse go ahead and ask your question and
then mute yourself
okay can you guys hear me okay i'm
trying
yes i heard that okay good sorry about
that um thank
you for taking my question um looking
for
updates one on the appeals process and
one
on the bank of america debit card issue
um perhaps you can address the appeals
process first
um and i'm just kind of looking for a
general update on that
like how many are waiting adjudication
what's the wait time how are people
being updated
how many have been resolved in claim and
favors can you give me
kind of a bucket response to what's
going on with the appeals
um sure elisa would you do you want to
do that or would you like me to
um sure the appeals process
is uh moving forward and it's we're
still using the same process
in pula so a lot of folks
you can you can appeal any determination
that's been made by dieter
and what we found is that folks
have filed a lot of appeals
sometimes when there was not even a
determination just
wanting someone to look at their claim
so the first step of the process
is adjudicators are reviewing all of
those claims
to see if they can just be resolved or
if there's actually something that needs
to go to an appeals referee
we currently have i believe the last
set of numbers i heard was about 900
legitimate deduplicated appeals
in pua to be scheduled and about 900
something in ui to be scheduled
our appeals referees are hearing those
uh one week they hear
ui cases one where they hear pua cases
so they're getting through uh one to two
hundred a week
so we've got about a little more than a
month's worth of hearings to go through
but we
are getting through those
on appeals i would add that 10
additional people
are being added to the appeals effort
next week just as a sample
kind of a week i'll take
the week of january 11th 723 appeals
were reviewed
568 were either redetermined
and paid the appeal was withdrawn
or if it was or it was determined not to
be a valid appeal
leaving 155 to be scheduled
and that's a fairly typical week in
terms of processing
so with 10 more people being added
obviously that is going to produce
a much quicker process
and by february 15th it's also
anticipated that more
hearing officers will be added
so when you have a huge backlog and you
make a huge push to resolve the cases
the next part of the system that gets
backed up is appeals
so that is going to be receiving
more and more attention so all of those
can be resolved
uh debit cards i'll kick that to you
lisa
the process with the debit cards is that
there are the people's bank of america
debit cards can be
frozen for a couple of reasons either
a fraud determination on deter side or
bank of america has found a hallmark of
fraud
from their system and their process is
different than ours
so folks need to call our call centers
and determine if it's something we can
release
we send over a list of claims that have
been released
every day to the bank of america
and then they have to lift the fraud
because they have to unfreeze the carbs
because
they're not our cards their bank of
america's cards
and in some cases if it was a
determination that was made by the bank
of america
because their fraud unit
or their hallmarks have triggered it it
needs to be released by the bank of
america
we know that's a complicated process for
folks and we are working on
resolving that um and my understanding
right now is that bank of america does
have a backlog
in terms of unfreezing cards i think
we've provided you
some of you with information about their
press
team because we can't answer questions
for them about
the backlog that they have
thank you so much so we've got um just
time for a couple more questions we did
get one um
from an anonymous individual that says
how we
how will dieter continue to incorporate
claimant advocates
to keep advocating for nevadans in the
future to make sure that the
unemployment claim process is
is more transparent to us
looks like barbara's typing an answer to
there you go so it has it has been one
of the recommendations of the strike
force to create
a position to advocate for
and communicate with our claimants
we have identified a person who will
take on
that task as part of their duties
as you know we can't just create a brand
new position in
the agency without going through the
state process
but we are we have found someone to at
least take that on
initially and we'll we we're going to be
meeting with and talking with the
governor's office about
about the recommendations in the report
we just we just received
we've seen drafts but we've just
received the final version so
we'll we'll come up with some action
steps out of the report
into in terms of how do we implement
all of these recommendations so we may
have an update for you on
creating a position or designating an
existing position to handle those
responsibilities
and we do think it's it's been very
helpful to
have information about clients
experiences
uh sometimes they'll see something
happening in the computer system
that we don't have any other way of
seeing and and their examples allow us
to go to the vendor
and resolve the issue so it's been very
valuable and we
we believe we need to keep that uh that
information coming into dieter
thank you director and then the final
question is a follow-up question from
michelle wendell
and she says dieter said it has
partially implemented the extensions and
changes
from the late december covered relief
bill what is left to do
and what groups of claimants may be or
unpaid right now
um so i i mentioned this in in
when i talked about our second priority
which is making sure
all claimants receive all the benefits
that they are entitled to one of the
things that the continued assistance
acted was it added
11 weeks to
[Music]
whatever program almost every program
that folks could be in so ui
pua but it also added
11 weeks to the pe uc which is the
additional weeks that have been given
in ui in recognition of how long
the uh this pandemic has lasted and the
those extended benefits uh the peuc
extended benefits also then
um have to be uh you get those weeks and
then
once those exhaust you go to state
extended benefit weeks i know this is
kind of a long answer
but um so we are still working out with
the department of labor what the
sequence is
of how you get your p e u c
weeks and then go to state extended
benefit weeks
because we have to get the order right
so that we don't cut off
your state extended benefit weeks
inadvertently by putting you in the
wrong system at the
wrong time so um that is a
been a more complicated dance than we
might hope
and we're still working out the details
on that so for
and and the worst part of course is the
people who are in the
those lines are the ones who you know
are are exhausting their benefits and
really need us to answer that question
but we can't answer it by ourselves
unfortunately so
we are in conversations with the
department of labor and making sure we
can
do that in a way that we don't cut off
benefits for folks
and i think there's still some new
programming that we have to put in line
because
there are new regulations about
documentation and identity verification
for new
applications and we've been taking the
applications but we need to make sure
that they um comply with the new
documentation
requirements i think you
think one thing that was really
eliminating to me
coming into this as a volunteer is the
complexity of dealing with the federal
government
um i mean even on just the 11 weeks to
be added to pua
you know i would say okay can this be
done this week
and it's oh we have a new department of
labor memo on this
and it's 11 pages and they say
oh well wait a minute we're not
there's a gap now on state extended
benefits in december
for three weeks so you can't add those
weeks because of that
and and you're like well of course you
can we've promised people
and you know you go through it and you
resolve it
but it is complex it is arcane
and this is a federal program so you
can't
do things unless the department of labor
says you can do
them and congress
and the president by waiting it makes it
extremely difficult
one of our recommendations is please
just do things in advance
i mean already they're talking about
potentially extending pua
through you know perhaps the third
quarter of 2021
well the strikeforce advice is if you're
going to do it do it now
allow that computer programming to be
done
now so that any problems in
reprogramming
don't cause delay and benefits
allow the guidance to come out
so again this kind of oh let's extend it
for
a month process is really hurting states
and it's really hurting claimants
and it can be avoided
great thank you very much okay everyone
um that concludes our event today
thank you